the best question to ask many people in
many circumstances whenever you're
faced with a situation just say if you
could do one thing what's the one most
important thing you can do
it's incredibly powerful
[Music]
uh jeff epstein thank you so much for
joining us at 20 minute leaders
it's wonderful to be here thank you for
having me okay so if i started to give a
brief bio about you i wouldn't be able
to ask you any questions because 20
minutes would be over
but just for context a previous
c04 of oracle but not just any cfo
because you've also been on the boards
of
the coolest companies currently on
twilio and shutterstock
incredible companies but you're on the
board of booking holdings
uh and you joined you said when it was a
billion dollars in revenues growing up
to 80.
billion dollars in market value growing
to 80 billion wow okay so billion
dollars in market value going up to 80
billion
but you're also on the on the board of
kaiser permanente
kaiser permanente is a large non-profit
healthcare
organization that provides both
healthcare hospitals and
health insurance for 12 million people
mostly in california the west coast
unbelievable you mentioned 230 000
employees
right unbelievable so you're sitting on
these boards i'm going to have to
at some point understand how do you even
juggle all these different positions and
how do you
then take the skills from the cfo at
oracle and now with apex which hopefully
we'll be able to get to as well but
but jeff how do you do it all it's a
serious question
uh i mean when i think of who i wanna
what like the level that i wanna get to
one day and have these incredible
experiences
uh you're the persona right now well
thank you very much well
you know i spent 25 years working
full-time as a chief financial officer
where every day you have people who
report to you and you you have a boss
and a board and
quarterly earnings and you know that was
a lot of responsibility
now that i'm retired from full-time work
i serve on these boards but
retired okay i just want to put the word
retired in front of everything that i
just said okay
well the difference between being a
board member is usually you go to the
board meeting you ask a lot of questions
you say boy it sounds like you got a lot
of problems i'll see your next board
meeting
and and management of the people have to
fix the problems we just
talk about them so you know there's a
lot of there's a lot of uh
governance responsibility and if
occasionally if you have to change the
ceo and things like that there's a lot
of work but
you know there are certain companies
like wells fargo and
over the last few years they've had
their pg e when going through bankruptcy
they have
a very intense experience but if the
company is doing well
it's uh it's a lot easier to be a board
member than to there's data made
responsibility of
being executive of course of course and
and of course i i generally
very rewarding as well because my job is
to ask questions
and so i love learning i love asking
questions and over the years after 40
years you've
asked a lot of questions you get to
learn a lot so it reminds me of the of
the nice story of when you go to the
doctor and
and you something is hurting in your
knee and the doctor hits your knee and
says okay now 500
please and you ask what you just hit the
knee and he said no no i've been
studying for 40 years
how to hit your knee so it sounds like
the questions that you're asking now
they're not just any questions there are
questions with
dozens of years and a wealth of
experience that you bring with you
right exactly i'll give you an example
of a board meeting i've been trying to
talk to some of my ceos about this
uh many of the people on this call might
have actually participated in a board
meeting
and in my mind there's sort of three
parts to a board meeting there's the
compliance part the audit committee
report
compensation committee things like that
which in a private company is very short
in a public company it's there's some
amount of time
and then the remainder of the time often
is
the management telling the board what
they've been doing
reporting on what's going on here here's
our product strategy here's our sales
and marketing strategy
here's our forecast i call that the
show-and-tell part
and then there's another part of the
meeting the third part which is
here are decisions we're thinking about
but we haven't made them yet
and we'd like to tell you you know we
have three choices and here's the pros
and cons of each choice we recommend
option a we're planning on doing option
a but
what do you think and maybe your your
questions and your guidance will change
your mind
so should we grow faster and burn more
money lose more money or should we grow
slower and make more money
right we we have one product just in the
u.s
should we add a second product in the us
or should we take our first product and
expand to the uk
you know those kinds of decisions so
i personally find the the decisions we
have not yet made
to be a much more valuable board meeting
as opposed to the show and tell and the
show-and-tell in my view can be done in
writing
you know put everything you know create
this big presentation send it out to the
board we can advance we'll read it all
right
we'll ask questions if you don't
understand it but to spend most of the
board
time just telling us what's in the
written material
is to me not taking full advantage of
the board
so that's an example of a kind of thing
that i've learned over the years which
you know 20 years ago i probably didn't
understand that now i try to
nudge my ceos in that direction how
would you describe your relationship
with your ceos as
a board member and you have quite a few
ceos that you have to be in touch with
is this a a friendly relationship is
this more of a
a boss employer relationship how what's
the
what's the intimacy like over there well
it depends uh
in if i were for the venture capital
partners or private equity partners
uh they essentially they are appointed
by their firm or
private equity firm maybe they hire the
ceo right and the companies that i'm
involved in
personally because i'm always an
independent the ceo
meets me and personally wants recruits
me to the board
so the ceo has essentially hired me to
be a board member right and essentially
the ceo could fire me if they decide
they don't like to get on the board
it's never happened but they could and
so you know
my my role is to help make the ceo as
effective as he or she can be
and so it's by asking questions by
telling stories and and
anecdotes so one way to think about it
is
so there's my dogs in the background i
love it it just adds
it so uh
the uh mark twain said that history
doesn't repeat itself but it does rhyme
and so if i've been involved in a
company before that had a similar
problem
i might tell the story here's what the
situation was it sounds similar here's
what they did here's what happened
but that doesn't mean you should do the
same thing because every situation is
different
right so you were telling me about about
mark twain
yeah so mark twain said history doesn't
repeat itself but it does rhyme
and so my interpretation of that is if i
if i'm in a board meeting and something
comes up with the company
and there's a challenge or a problem
i'll say well in two or three other
situations
i had a similar type of situation here's
what the situation was here's what the
company did
it worked or it didn't work that doesn't
mean that you the ceo should do the same
thing because your
situation is going to be somewhat
different but if you
if you never had any similar experience
you're you're
you're flying blind whereas if you have
the benefit of mine or other people's
experience
you can triangulate and piece together
the pieces of the puzzle
and say well i think this is relevant
and then you make up your own mind
so i basically work as a board member
not by telling people what to do but by
asking questions
and by telling stories that i think
that's incredible and you know i'm
i i haven't gotten to that position and
i very much hope to one day
be able to be this ceo or you're on the
board of so
wait for that request one day but but it
sounds to me that a lot of these things
you know you can look up online and read
case studies from business schools and
and understand that how you get to point
b from point a but
but it sounds like a lot of the added
benefit that you would bring to the
table
is not just from it's not just a and
then b but it's the whole process and
the whole
and the relationships and the
intricacies that and the complexity that
goes into it
so you really you can you know all the
details of the whole process and not
just the outcome right
yeah it's not only the details it's also
the emotional impact
of having lived through it right so
you've probably heard
the phrase raise money when you can not
when you need it
and if you hear that you say okay well
that makes sense that's logical but i've
actually
lived through it and i'll tell you that
story i was the cfo of doubleclick
during the internet boom
and our stock went from we went public
at 250 million dollars
of market value and we were up to 11
billion dollars
so we were trading at 22 times revenue a
huge price
we were still losing money we were
growing fast and we were the leading
internet advertising technology company
but by any measure the company was fully
valued i mean we
clearly weren't undervalued uh and so we
decided to
raise money and we did a follow-on
offering and we were in the market
raising 700 million dollars it's a
public company
and we had a road show which started
monday morning we were in a price
thursday night
and on wednesday at lunch i'm presenting
uh
to investors at a luncheon meeting and i
got a call from my office
said that the message said call nasdaq
so i call him nasdaq
and they say you know we have a problem
and i go really what's the problem he
said well we have
a lot of sell orders and they said
really well how many he says well
we have so many sell orders and no
buying interest
that we're stopping trading in your
stock and so
for the rest of that wednesday afternoon
our stockton trade
and what had happened was there was an
article in the usa today that morning
about how we
doubleclick was violating people's
privacy and that just spooked investors
they didn't know what to think about it
so we sit with our investment bankers
wednesday night and we say what's going
to happen and they
predict accurately that the stock's
going to open up tomorrow morning down
20 percent
so a 9 billion evaluation and the
question is should we just pull the
offering or should we go ahead with the
offering at the 20
lower valuation and my feeling was
the price that it was yesterday is
irrelevant the question is is 9 billion
a fair price yes or no and for a company
with 500
revenue boosting money i thought that
was a very still a very good valuation
and even though we had 200 mega cash we
didn't need the money i thought it was
just a sensible thing to raise money
when you can so we
i recommend it and then we went ahead
and raised money and then of course the
whole
market internet market collapsed this
the advertising market collapsed our
revenue over the next two years dropped
by 50
from wow 500 billion to 250 million but
we had 700 million cash so
we had a very strong balance sheet so
it's one thing to say
it's nothing to live through it and
that's unbelievable
so and we all have you know if you're
old enough you all have stories like
that
that's just unbelievable and of course
throughout this whole thing i i gently
forgot to mention that
and that you are teaching one of the
most popular courses at stanford
uh which i very much hope to take myself
one day hopefully this upcoming winter
and you're also an operating partner at
bessemer one of the world's leadest
leading venture capital firm what do you
do there what does that even mean an
operational partner
well i'll talk about that but i do want
to talk about the class too
yes an operating partner means i'm not
an investing partner
so i don't make any decisions to invest
bessemer's money
i can invest my own money side by side
with bessemer and
since i was a career cfo what i've done
is i've
created a cfo advisory board among
bessemer's portfolio companies cfos
so we have 100 portfolio companies cfos
and in any company
there might be 100 or 200 or 300
employees that cfo probably has no one
else in the company to talk to about
a finance related issue right but across
the portfolio there's a hundred people
to talk to
so we meet in pre-cove at times we meet
in person once a quarter now we're
meeting online we have an online
platform where people are asking each
other questions a couple times a week
there's a big database of questions over
the last seven years so it's a very
rich valuable resource of a peer group
among our portfolio companies and so i
do that with the cfos and then the ceos
help them in business or finance or
capital raising questions or operation
questions as well wow
incredible about the class or the lean
launch pad class is
it's in the winter quarter it's
engineering 245 in the graduate school
of engineering but uh
business students typically are half the
class and
what it's teams of four or five students
with a
startup idea and in 10 weeks they're
required to
interview 100 potential customers wow
build multiple prototypes
uh have ex run many experiments
and with any luck they generate their
first revenue by the 10th week
and we've had now uh i guess this is my
this will be my eighth year teaching so
wow we've had
quite a 100 teams or so uh
graduate from the class and we've had
maybe 15 teams actually
form uh companies and get funding and
some of them are doing quite wow
that's that's huge revenues and some
very exciting companies like uh
one of them is uh is fresh technologies
which is
ai for grocery ordering one is zoom
uh uber for children or for schools
type of system one of them is nova which
is
uh financial uh it's it's getting credit
for
for illegal immigrants who might
otherwise find it hard to get credit
so a lot of really interesting ideas and
it's terrific i just love
working with these incredibly talented
students and it's a great experience for
students to
get as close to running a business while
you're still
without dropping out so i love it
i just get inspired by again in the
first few minutes you mentioned that
you're tired
and i think it just speaks to your
passion to everything that you're doing
that you're considered yourself you're
considering yourself retired yet
you do more than you know people do in a
lifetime and
it's to me i mean that's really the
inspiration you know all the other tips
and tricks that they're amazing
very insightful but the fact that at the
end i get to speak to somebody who's
calling themselves retired yet they're
doing
extraordinary things i mean almost
everything that you're doing here is a
world-class level that any any amazing
entrepreneur would wish they could do
and to me that's inspiring and that's
definitely one of my goals in life
to be able to say that i'm retired at
work as much as you do
and jeff i have to ask cfo oracle
everybody knows oracle and and the
incredible things that this company has
done
you've seen it also in in earlier on
tell
what does even the cfo do i don't get to
speak to many cfos in my daily life
well of course the cfo at any size
company does
uh is responsible for the same functions
you know accounting treasury
uh risk capital raising
uh financial planning and forecasting uh
what
uh the difference is is that when i was
the cfo of doubleclick years ago i
started out we had 180 people
and i probably did 25 of the work myself
i would run the excel models myself
and then wow the investor presentations
myself and then i delegate 75 percent of
the time
you know you start off in your career
you do 100 yourself you have no one to
delegate to
right at that time you know i was i was
a manager i had a team
initially i had a team of maybe 10
people it grew to you know probably at
the peak
there i would say maybe 100 people in
finance
out of 2000 typically 5 of the head
counts in finance
but at oracle i did virtually zero
percent personally and
delegated 100 so if i had written the
investor relations
presentation myself the head of investor
relations would have said
you know why am i here so sure even if i
have ideas about investor relations
you have to i think that the best way to
do it is to sit down to have investor
relations say
you know here are some of my ideas but
you know you go off and do it and then
i'll
give you some guidance but fundamentally
it's a leadership role
as opposed to uh and it's a
decision-making role as opposed to a
doing role so
it changes quite a bit oracle is an
incredibly well-run
organization it has been for decades and
40 profit margins uh and wow
good at what it does what i was asking
though which was i think
i think it's very interesting i mean
you've grown
as a cfo from you know early stage
startups to se
in terms of annual revenues all the way
up to the billions it can't be the same
mindset
and the same you know day-to-day
responsibilities and
and thinking you have to be
transitioning yourself so what are some
what is that like transitioning from
you know millions to billions well
i did it over 25 years it wasn't
overnight so
still sounds very fast that that is a
big difference
and between doubleclick and oracle i was
the cfo of
a big group at nielsen the television
ratings and internet ratings companies
so
they were a global company with many
thousands of employees so i had that
that exposure to large companies
you know it's you know one difference
that you know larry ellison
years ago the founder and chairman of
oracle
uh he oracle started with a country
structure grew very fast in the early
days
and they had oracle us oracle uk oracle
japan
and one day around uh i'd say 20 years
ago
he said we we are a big company now but
we're operating like 75 small companies
and what we should do is centralize and
so and to take advantage of the
economies of scale
and so over the course about two years
they went from a 75 different country
structure to one global structure
so each country had its own ceo and its
own cfo and then
when it was all over there was no other
ceos no other cfos i was the only person
who worked with the title of cfo
um one head of marketing things like
that
uh and their trade-offs either could be
centralized or decentralized but oracle
was
an example of an extreme case of very
effective and efficient centralization
in contrast
booking holdings grew through
acquisition and we owned booking.com
priceline kayak opentable and
other companies and each of those
businesses had its own
not only its own ceo and cfo but it had
its own complete business
right there's almost no shared resources
and it also ran
extremely well as a very decentralized
entrepreneurial organization so there's
no right answer
but i think whatever whichever strategy
you have you want to execute it well
unbelievable jeff i can't believe our
time is almost up it's so sad every time
you know give me one or two earned
secrets true earned secrets that
that you would give me a young
entrepreneur
just starting my journey hopefully
trying to make it
going to try to make an impact and a
dent in the world in a positive way
what are really extraordinary things
that i should be keeping in mind
over the next decade as i pursue this
dream
well uh if let me ask answer that two
ways for entrepreneurs
if you're starting a company from
scratch uh what we teach in this class
is
the first step is to get to product
market fit and so what you wanted
my advice for most companies software
companies
is to try to create the smallest
possible product
with the smallest number of customers
who love you a lot
and uh paula graham the founder y
combinator puts it this way said you'd
rather have 10 customers who love you
than a million customers who like you
yeah and the logic is if you have
if you've created a product that's 10
customers love i'm pretty confident you
can find it 11th and then you can find a
12.
but if you have a lot of customers who
just like you you know tomorrow they're
going to go on and like something else
right so you want to start a small if
you think about you know
facebook started just at harvard and
within two weeks he had 90 percent of
all harvard students
loving facebook and airbnb started with
literally renting
an air bed in someone's apartment so
they started with a very small
product view and a very small number of
customers but they built huge companies
and so i think
you know you can't build a jet engine
company that way but for many businesses
you can uh that's on the entrepreneur's
side on the if you're an employee
my favorite uh sort of tactic
is if when you're interviewing for a job
you're in it you have a boss
and ask your boss tell your boss to say
uh
listen let's pretend you hire me let's
imagine you hire me and a year from now
you're sitting giving me your
my performance review and you say boy
it's i made a great decision jeff
hiring you for the following three
because you've accomplished the
following three things
what are those three things what it does
is it forces your hiring manager to
crystallize
what his or her expectations are of you
and then if you know exactly what the
expectations are then you can
exceed them can i reverse that and use
that as the hiring manager as a tactic
to really
align expectations properly and sort of
give my ideal performance review ahead
of time and then
and then have them try to match it
throughout the year yeah i think that's
a great a second application
i love it is when you if you started
your job and you haven't already had
that conversation
have that conversation with your boss
the first week of your job
uh because it's you know some many
managers are not a good leader we'll do
that anyway
but many managers and leaders aren't
experienced and just don't know that
that tactic and and and then you can go
for a long time thinking you're
doing what you should be doing and
realizing that you're not necessarily
focused on the top four i imagine that
that grows in a few orders of magnitude
and tech when a lot of
leaders are not necessarily leaders but
there are more you know tech experts who
have grown
to be team leaders organically through
the organization
yeah a similar example i i focus there
on three things but
an even more powerful technique is to
focus on one thing so
i sat at a dinner party once next to
george roberts of kkr
uh colbert travis roberts and we were
talking about
the problems of education in america and
he said you know jeff if you could do
one thing to improve education in
america what would it be
and i thought a lot about education but
i actually never answered i never
thought of that particular what's one if
i only could do one thing what's the one
most important thing
and i realized that's actually the best
question to ask
many people in many circumstances
whenever you're faced with a situation
just say
if you could do one thing what's the one
most important thing you can do
it's incredibly powerful i love it i
just love it jeff
before we leave i have to ask you a
question that i asked every person on
the show
and i'm especially curious to hear your
answer i'd love to hear three words
that you would use to describe yourself
or if i were to ask any of the ceos
that you've worked with whether they're
in shutterstock or or
booking or kaiser what how would they
what would they think of when they think
of jeff epstein
curious yeah analytical
helpful i love it jeff thank you so much
for the inspiration thank you for the
time
i can't even imagine how you're juggling
everything that you're doing yet you're
still giving me these 20 minutes
and so thank you for your generosity
i'll add that as the fourth word
and uh and yeah have it and stay safe
and stay healthy
great michael thank you very much and
i'll see you i'll see you in class in
the winter
uh well i i'm sorry to say you actually
have to apply to the class and get
accepted so that
that would be an application i'm just
i'm just putting in the hint but
i'll definitely apply sounds good i'm
planting the seeds
okay take care bye bye bye